BUT NOW IT IS TIME TO PLAY SAINT
HASHTAG'S DAY.
SAINT HASHTAG'S DAY.
ALL ACROSS IRELAND AND MANY
PARTS OF THIS COUNTRY, ST.
PATRICK'S DAY WAS MARKED BY
PARTIES, PARADES AND THE
OCCASIONAL DISPLAY OF WILDLY
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR.
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU A A PHOTO
FROM A ST. PATRICK'S DAY
FESTIVITY AND FOR 250, YOU HAVE
TO HASHTAG IT.
FIRST UP, THIS DOUBLE FISTER.
YES, PAUL.
>> ZACH MCFADDEN'S 300: "THIS IS
GUINESS!"
>> Chris: YEAH.
POINTS.
>> APRIL.
>> I'M GONNA GO WITH HASHTAG
IRISH CROSSFIT.
>> Chris: YEAH, MM-HMM.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> Chris: POINTS.
NEXT ONE, THIS LASS WITH AN
EXPOSED ASS.
>> BEEN THERE.
>> Chris: PAUL.
>> HASHTAG NORMAL TUESDAY IN
BOSTON.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
SEAN.
>> PEE-LATES.
>> Chris: POINTS.
APRIL.
>> HASHTAG HOW I MET YOUR
MOTHER.
>> Chris: YEAH, POINTS.
POINTS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: NEXT ONE, SIGN OF THE
TIMES.
SIGN OF THE TIMES.
-- THIS MAN IS TAPED TO A STOP
SIGN.
>> OH, I'M ENVIOUS.
>> Chris: BUT IT DOES HAVE A
BEER RIGHT THERE, SO I GUESS
HE'S OKAY.
SEAN.
>> HASHTAG I WILL BE A BUTTERFLY
ONE DAY.
ONE DAY. WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING
AT!
>> Chris: POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
WHAT ABOUT THIS MICKEY RIGHT
THERE?
APRIL.
>> HASHTAG FURRY WALK OF SHAME.
>> Chris: YEAH.
POINTS.
>> OH, THAT'S GOOD. OH THAT'S
GOOD.
>> Chris: FINALLY THESE
FIGHTING IRISH, THESE FIGHTING
IRISH.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE BEING
RACIALLY SENSITIVE TO YOU.
ARE YOU OKAY?
>> NO.
I AM REALLY PISSED OFF ABOUT
THAT.
>> HASHTAG STOP THE HATE.